I think this is a really good example of a difficult figure.
That's controversial that people bring up to me a lot.
And you interviewed twice,
which is courtesy Arvin mentioned small, AKA mentioned small bug,
which is his pseudonym that he goes by is his blog.
Can you tell me about who he is? Sure. Why is he interesting?
What of his ideas are interesting.
Briefly? He invented the concept of the red pill.
So Curtis mentioned mobile blog had a blog called unqualified reservations.
You can still find it online. It's very verbose.
He writes at length very, very bright. Um,
his perspective is very heretical.
So a lot of things that we take for granted in our liberal democracy, uh,
he regards is not only incorrect, which is downright absurd and does not.
He does not take what many people view as the basis of
American political discourse as the basis for his thought.
So
when you're starting with someone who is basically repudiating, uh,
kind of the Western worldview, we're not the Western world.
You'd like the American [inaudible]. A lot of people are gonna, of course,
regard him as dangerous or, uh, someone who was verboten. Um,
he's a very bright person. Um.
Why is he such a toxic figure?
Because if you are blue pills,
if you are the guardians of what is
acceptable discourse, then you have to make sure your forts are secured.
And that any figure outside of this acceptable discourse has to be marginalized
and regarded as radioactive as possible.
You don't want to let in these kind of ideas,
that would be destructive to your headlamp.
Well, so let's dig into it.
So like he I've read a few things by him,
but then I hear that in a bunch of places,
him being called a racist, a white supremacist, new fascist.
So on I go to his Wikipedia. Yeah.
There's a view on race section. Let me, let me read it. Okay.
You Garvin's opinions have been described as racist with his writings
interpreted as supportive of slavery,
including the belief that whites have higher IQs than blacks for genetic
reasons.
The Arvin himself maintains that he's not a racist because while he doubts
that quote, all races are equally smart.
The notion quote that people who score higher on IQ tests and in some sense,
superior human beings is quote creepy.
He also disputes being an outspoken advocate for slavery, though.
He has argued that some races are more suited for slavery than others. Quote,
it should be obvious that although I'm not a white supremacy, white nationalist,
I am not exactly allergic to the stuff you Arvin wrote in a post that linked
approvingly of, I don't know these people, Steve sailor. Sailor. Yeah.
He's from Jared Taylor and other racialists. Yeah. So, okay.
So like w w why my question is.
Well,
let me just say one sentence in the same way that you had,
you were mentioned that guy earlier,
who was defending some aspects of communism,
and that is in some contexts acceptable.
When you think about it's like this should be radioactive, right?
The fact that he is engaging with these ideas, uh,
in anything other than this has to be repeated at all costs is what renders him
to large extent racist.
That's really interesting.
So there are some topics you can be nuanced and nuanced and some not.
And communism is still a topic that you can be nuanced about, right?
It's difficult, but you can be a race in this,
like talking about slavery and IQ differences based on race is a
topic that I guess is radioactive to a degree where you can't
even say anything,
even if it's like nuanced or not even like
making a point, it's like touching it as you make another point. Yeah.
And understandably, because you can understand that I'm going to steal man the,
the their point. Cause you can understand the point. It's like,
you're just talking about Hitler. Once this foot gets in the door,
that some people are inherently slaves or some people are inherently better than
others. It really quickly, you know, collapses.
So that would be their perspective.
Like if I were to give criticism of his.
Let me just say one more thing. Racist is also used to describe Alex Jones.
Alex, doesn't talk about race.
Racist is a shorthand for a certain percentage of the population to
let you know,
do not bother investing in this person any further they're off limits.
Definitely.
Racism and sexism is a thing that's not used to shut down conversation.
That's quite absurd. Uh, by, by small percent.
Jared Taylor and Steve sailor at Jared Taylor interviewed him for my book.
He would be regarded in any sense as a racist. What's.
The difference between racist and racialists. So.
Racial lists, I mean,
this is splitting hairs and now I'm going to be all radioactive.
Jared Taylor runs into called Amarin. And this is, I mean,
his perspective is that there are inherent differences for the races and you
cannot live side by side. Um, well, whites and blacks should not be living.
And by the way, for people who don't know, this is out of context,
you have written a great book that includes some of these concepts called the
new right. Which is not includes these concepts, but talks about, yeah. Well,
it's more about the growth of the, the community, uh,
around the, the alt-right and all those kinds of things.
Right? So,
and his point about IQ it's like if you had a population, the Dutch,
right. I think that the tallest people on the earth, and if you said, well,
the Dutch are the best people on earth. Why? Because they're the tallest.
It's like, you're a crazy person.
So if is scoring low an individual on an IQ test,
that means there's somehow a lower quality person. Well,
maybe one very specific aspect, but I mean, if there are good human being,
I've got friends who are low IQ. All my friends are like, you're frankly,
compared to me, sounded like Trump there for a second. Well,
I don't have any other choices. No, one's going to be at my level.
You're the smartest person since Abraham Lincoln, that I've,
that I've ever seen.
Unlike him, I actually am honest. So,
so he is someone who very much swims in heretical
ideas, Aristotle.
Here's another thing like if you bring up that Aristotle said that some people
are born to be slaves. He wasn't speaking about race.
He was just meant people's souls, HL, Mencken, who was a great heretic in and,
uh, uh, early 20th century figure. Uh,
one of his quotes that I say all the time,
which people have seen a lot in this past year that the average man does not
want to be free. He merely wants to be safe. That I think is, I don't know,
I'm not familiar with what Mudbug is saying about slavery because his writing is
ponderous.
But that certainly is something I think that is undeniable that I think more
people are realizing there's a large percent of the population that is actively
disinterested in freedom. And the more responsibilities that entails.
Well, I mean, really, it's just the word slavery.
If you want to make some kind of point or even think about the topic
outside the context of this is a horrible thing that happened in the United
States.
History and other country's history. So let's be clear.
I mean, very important then there's slavery going on today.
And then a lot of people argue that, uh, uh,
sex trafficking and all those kinds of things. I mean, there's,
there's atrocities going on today that, you know, uh,
talking about it in a way that's not immediately saying this is the most
horrible thing that happened ever. You know,
it's something I think about a lot is like,
if I want to say something controversial,
I should do so with skill with care.
And only about things I care about.
Well, here's where I would disagree. I not, when I say things,
I often say things that are controversial,
or I will say uncontroversial things in a controversial way,
because it's a useful mechanism to alienate people you don't want around you.
Because if there are people who are going to be shocked by certain topics,
like we should have ended world war II, like even as a hypothesis,
they just clutch their pearls. They're like, Oh,
you want the Holocaust to happen?
I can't discuss most things with you because you're not interested in having
conversations. You're interested in your emotional response. Yeah.
I think I see things differently. Maybe this is a bit of a devil's advocate,
but what in at least the modern discourse of like Twitter and social media and
so on. I find that if you do that, you're not actually
removing the people that are not thoughtful and kind and so on.
You're actually attracting loud people like a small number of them.
They come over and start yelling at, you start yelling there,
basically ruin the party by showing up and just
screaming. And so all the thoughtful people leave.
Well, that's why you have to be a very heavy blocker.
You have to block people on Twitter because you have to cultivate your audience
and have them. Like a lot of times people come at me, I don't care.
Then they'll start attacking members of my audience. And then I'm like, dang,
I got to block them because they've won this one. Cause I can't have that.
Yeah. I don't. I on,
on necessarily provoking people feels, um.
It's, it's it's this is beta testing.
You try to break the system and see what works.
You put up as much pressure as possible.
This is very much computer stuff that you should be able to appreciate the point
being when you have a program,
you're trying to intentionally sit there and do as many mistakes,
see what go wrong. Right. Is that not common?
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So you're saying that's,
that's a way to see communication with the world, as you say,
something uncontroversial and uncontroversial way and that blocks
people.
Or does it trigger them? Do they roll their eyes? Well, you know what,
it's going to be the emotional response. Are they gonna start yelling?
The problem is that w the reason I can't think like this, or I can't,
because I'm not sure about the points I'm trying to make. Uh,
always like I'm not always a hundred percent sure that I'm right about things
like, so, um, in being thoughtful,
I'm afraid that I'll turn off within an
eloquently phrased or even incorrect statement.
I will do damage that can't be undone in terms of having a
good conversation about a topic. So I want to be very careful about, like,
I'm not saying afraid. Fear is not what I'm talking about.
I think fear is, is, uh,
like not saying something out of fears at the core of the many of the problems
of the world today, but I'm just saying, be, say stuff with care.
If I'm going to touch race as a topic,
it feels like you really should be deeply first
have a point to make, like, you really care about a point you want to make.
And second think deeply about how to say that point in a way that communicates
it the best and, and touching,
I would say, listen, I've, I've, uh,
on your show, which is, which is great. I mean, I'd like to say,
thank you for having [inaudible] mobile. You are welcome.
That's the, uh, that's the name of the show? Uh,
so thank you for having me a couple of times. It's,
it's great to sort of get him to in this loose way to talk about different.
I don't think we talked about race at all, so no,
but I'm just bringing it back to what you were asking, which is,
if you read the Wikipedia, the perspective is going to be,
this guy talks about slavery constantly,
where it's completely disproportionate to his work,
but even on your show can tell even not.
Outside of the very stuff that he's not ultra careful about.
He's not a nuanced. Yeah.
He's not afraid to say something just like, I would say,
let me just criticize him.
My face is not used as me carelessly say something controversial, right?
Like, um, I'm not saying he doesn't go like, you know, that makes them,
it's a very different thing than, uh, uh,
somebody who on purpose says something controversial stuff, uh,
like Milo Yiannopoulos, sorry. I forgot my Milo, whatever his name is.
Yeah. Which is really nice to see that he's a genuine person who thoughtful.
He doesn't mean to,
but he's just Kara carelessly seems to say things
that, uh, I feel like damaged the rest of his body of work.
Yeah. I can't really speak for him,
but I would guess his point is once you're swimming in this kind of
worldview, you're going to be anathema already.
So there's no pleasing these people. So why bother trying?
Yeah. I think that's a deeply, that's a,
that's a black pill way of seeing the world I blacked filled at all,
because it's a cynical way that these people, so like, it's, it's saying that
you're, it's a very kind of way of thinking. Like, I'll say whatever I want,
whoever comes along with me.
Earlier said yourself,
that race racism has been weaponized as a way to shut down conversation.
So I think his perspective would be,
I am so outside the mainstream in my worldview that I know I'm going to be
called racism racist.
So there's no point in trying to be nuanced because I'm already going to get the
Scarlet letter. Yeah.
I just disagree with that because for example, I'm one,
I am one person that he turned off okay. By his carelessness.
And I think I should be a good target. I should be somebody that's fair. And,
um, I'm just like, he,
it's very convenient to think that there's ridiculous people out there,
which they are, who call everybody racist and sexist currently.
And then you can't please them. So I'm not even going to try. No,
but there's like this gray area of people that I don't listen to.
The outrage culture, whatever. I don't,
this Wikipedia article means nothing to me. Like I,
I'm not going to write what, I'm more,
I'm just seeing this careless person. And if he's going to be careless about,
uh, like race like this, I feel like if I walk along with them long enough,
I'm going to catch the carelessness.
I'm going to lose like, Oh.
I'll defend your perspective there. Then you can, okay.
This is, this is good. I'm taking notes.
I talked to Eric Weinstein after you guys talked about me on your Chanel's was
that we had a good conversation. He invited.
Me on his show. That'd be an amazing conversation. And.
We got on the phone and his concern fairly. He goes,
I don't want you to come on my show for the purposes of clowning.
Me and I would never do that. Yeah. It would never,
ever, ever, we might not be aware of who you are.
That's why he wants to feel me out. He's like, you know, when he hears troll,
it could mean a lot of different things. And I,
we had a very conversation a very much,
it was very clear that that's not where the conversation would go.
But I think when you are going to be on someone's show,
there is a responsibility that they're not going to have to pay a cost for
having you as their guests. So if you're a pro,
if you were put off by how he wasn't that live streams or two, I did like,
I understand where you're coming from. I think he's very, very bright,
but you have a very,
you have a different audience than I do when you're going for something
different than, than I am.
No, no, I, uh, in my interest, the sense of you wouldn't feel safe with him.
Yeah. I wouldn't feel safe with them, but he's, he's born in for me.
I think I th I would like to actually talk to him one day. Uh,
Alex Jones is crossed the other line for me.
Well, you could do it legally with me tip the episode that never released it.
No, it's, it's one of those things will be, uh, one when there's finally,
they'll, they'll make a history channel documentary about you and I,
and how it all went wrong.
Like the cult that we started and everybody killed themselves. And, uh,
there was, uh, uh,
we'll release it then because there'll be like unseen footage.
This is how it started is it would be black and white
in a basement somewhere in New York. My mother's basement.
Uh, this explains so much okay.